we good what's up what's going on nice
to see you nice move
let's start off by saying this I thought
I asked everyone to give us a review I
thought that was gonna impact the rate
of the downloads sorry I think you're
gonna have to move the back I can see it
spiking cuz it's too close good yeah
start again ok we're back I thought when
we asked everyone to leave us a review I
did so because I thought I was gonna
help us with the downloads we're hacking
this process I've learned two things the
first podcasting is a wild west still
apple doesn't give you anything that you
need
the second is I'm not sure that's the
best thing to do we good
that's right we can keep riffing we good
alright so what do we think is the best
way to get more reviews or more
downloads which is our goal subscribe so
subscribe but so basically a tell your
friends be like yo there's a business
podcast out there and B if you go in
iTunes and subscribe that that spikes us
in the charts so some people like to
unsubscribe and then risa because that
creates the like the charts say oh
there's more subscribers today yeah I
think that's the barstool trick so
subscribe then unsubscribe and then
resubmit a times because here's the deal
if chart and I don't get to a hundred
thousand listeners per episode of X
weeks or months we're gonna start
charging for this pocket yeah or we just
get so bored or like impatient we were
too impatient
no we're gonna make it so you have to
pay money to listen happen so you want
to start talking about some ideas first
of all I think we should start this the
Twitter weight-loss thing we show that
that's pretty interesting did you sign
up for it I signed up I just ate a big
old plate of veggies just now because
now cuz I'm like oh [__] this is
starting so explain what this is okay so
when you're on camera you predict this
happens a lot but you get self-conscious
but also we are both trying to lose
weight our friend Justin is doing a
thing where we have then what did you
venom venom owe him money
so he tweeted out hey I got an
experiment for weight loss 30 days if
you want in let me know and you had to
venmo him 800 bucks I did know just did
it right away just a pop mcpot commit
myself into it
and then he's gonna send us a blood
glucose monitor and say 'then you for 28
days 20 days and basically the way it
works is he's gonna send a nutrition
plan and like an eating plan but if you
and if you stick to it you'll be fine
but well problem is most people don't
stick to it so here's how it's gonna
work
if your blood glucose levels go out of
the range like the healthy range the
weight loss range that he's gonna
prescribe for us so first it's gonna
monitor your baseline then he's gonna
say okay cool here's the range I want
you to stay in if you stay in that range
for the day he then moves you back 25
bucks for the day and if you don't he
keeps your money
I love it and he is doing this in a way
where he's buying all of our monitors
yes which typically cost I think $300
400 bucks if we stick to it by the end
of this challenge we've paid $100 we've
lost a bunch of weight and we got paid
back all our money if you stick to it if
you don't it's a hundred bucks now and
then if you if you if you do it to the
letter of the law you get this four
hundred hour device for a hundred
dollars and you lost your weight I love
it sick deal and we should explain who
he is he's the founder of this thing
called kettle and fire he also I think
is one of the founders of perfect keto
yeah so - keto products basically yeah
and I have no idea but I imagine his
businesses collectively are in the 50 or
60 million dollar in revenue range so
like he sees a lot he says he's at a
hundred million plus run rate for his to
product for kettle and fire and perfect
where did he say that on his website oh
good for him yeah I didn't know that
which is very crazy for a keto product
yeah so it sounds like he's thinking of
a new business yeah go ahead and copy
that yeah so I like it so what we'll do
is when we get the device what a
shout-out our blood glucose during the
show I'm doing it I also use my body
tutor
where I take pictures of everything that
I eat right and I send it to my so I ate
that doughnut just now I'm gonna send
that to them and they're gonna shave me
you ate it well there's more out there
I'll take a picture of it okay but all
I've eaten today is a doughnut in an
orange I'm good all right cool cool
weight-loss idea I like it just amazed
good stuff okay what's up what okay so
last episode
had your buddy here and we he told me
about this thing where he had invested
in the company that's doing drone
window-washing yes I thought that was
crazy fascinating and I went and
researched in a bunch there's another
competitor that's raised money and
drones I don't think at the right words
to describe it because when I think of
drones I think of like a quadcopter
these are things that like they look
like the normal so when you're pulling
up the scaffolding or when you're
pulling up like the what do you call it
it's like an elevator
yeah an elevator up and the guys are
standing on it and wiping it looks like
that but there's a robot on there that
is doing it instead of people right so
it's not flying you're saying it's not
flying why do they call it a drone bin
cuz technically it is robot drone means
honor
unmanned vehicle I think okay so
technically the right and so another
company called sky I forget what's
called they raised three million to do
this and so this morning what I did in
yesterday morning is I went I googled
Manhattan skyscraper window cleaners and
I found like the top three four people
and I called them today to talk to them
and I got I was talking to them and
they're gonna call me back with some
more details but my takeaway from this
industry is incredibly uh segmented so
like fragrance fragmented like small
like twenty to ten to twenty million
dollar businesses and there's probably
five or ten of them in New York right so
it's like the guy Brian from one hundred
got junk right this is how the hauling
business was and you know before he sort
of started aggregating all these small
fragments and local players and you've
always had this thesis which is you
could do the 1-800 GOT JUNK model for
other businesses yeah so I would do it
for irrigation for lawn mowing for
painting which is already happening and
for landscaping right and it sounds like
window washing is in that vein yeah so
maybe you don't even need these freaking
drones to do it but that's definitely a
cool stick so the private equity play is
you go you buy up these businesses they
have a book of business they do
recurring revenue probably with the same
buildings and you say okay I'm gonna buy
this five million dollar a year business
for eight million or ten million tell me
ten million
bucks or you do smaller ones you buy a
bunch of $1,000,000 a year businesses
and then you could bring in this
technology to increase the efficiency so
they're getting 50% margin you could get
70% and theirs to play books to look at
if you wanted to replicate this the
first is dentist is so PE right now is
gobbling up dentists --is dentistry
dentist dentists we have friends who are
doing this yes you have like three like
see ever looked into doing it and then
like two other guys I think we know they
love it and so what they do is they find
a dentist that does two million a year
in revenue and they buy the keys like 60
ready to retire in a few years and they
buy it for maybe if it's like a three
million dollar revenue thing they
probably buy it for like a million
dollars yeah but basically they'll buy
it at like one I think one to two X Y
bruh which is crazy yeah so basically
they depend back your money in a urine
yeah so they buy it for the dentist's
salary right times two and they give him
you know you still keep this little
piece and you keep getting your salary
but you don't have to run this business
anymore
in the sort of all the administration
and marketing and they centralize it so
they'll go buy ten of these dentistry's
and then they'll put it'll be like okay
we'll have one central office that's
doing Facebook Ads
driving traffic to all these we'll bring
all your billing stuff into one central
place cuz why do you need four people
doing billing because health insurance
is you know all complicated and so they
centralized which makes each one more
efficient and basically the dentist is
already playing golf two days or three
days a week and they're like look here's
a you know accelerated retirement for
you and the goal here is you just you
kind of become a little bit of a just a
marketing company and so we're well we
missed the punch line though a couple of
these roll-ups I think like in Canada
70% of dentists you know numbers wrong
but something like that a huge
percentage of the of all the dentist's
office have been rolled up now in Canada
and a couple of them have been taken
public the roll-ups what four three
billion dollars name um I don't know the
names okay yeah because anyway if you
want a Google dentistry roll up Canada
it goes public I would do that and then
the other model that you can look at for
this there's old people homes nursing
homes
like so many P this is like so my wife's
dad owns three senior care facilities
yeah and so I was looking into this
because I was like wow this thing is a
cash cow and I think it's soul-crushing
that's the problem with it because he
was like hey you guys want to take this
over and we were just like oh the money
is there but like it sucks I don't want
this to be like my life you know like I
think in general people want to avoid
nursing homes at all cost and so getting
into it earlier than you need to it was
painful but he's making money - how much
does it make a month
oh you know it depends on the size so
basically with a bottle is you go and
you you can buy an existing nursing home
but what he looks for is he says okay
this is existing nursing home it's got
28 beds but it's permitted for 42 and so
he'll either just buy it he'll build out
the other beds and so and then the other
thing is he'll buy things that are
motels today so Motel the room or the
bed might rent for like I don't know 150
dollars a night and so that becomes
let's call it four grand
you know ish a month and what he does is
for for senior care you're charging 7
grand 8 grand here in California for
each bed and you can put two beds in a
room and then you could do memory care
special you know dementia ward on the
bottom and that's like 12 grand and so
just put all the [__] up cells into
it the problem is is that your upsell is
a dementia award you know so it's like
all right clearly a lot of money can be
made
you are definitely providing but there's
a service to people yeah you're not
scamming people right scamming people
it's but it is a it's a it's a saddening
business to be in yeah and so for these
so we're getting off track but let's go
so so my father-in-law owns a moving
company in New York and it's a medium
middle medium-sized business and it's
done the same amount like let's say
let's just say some number between 10
and 30 million in sales every single
year and real profitable I go how do you
make this bigger he goes I'd have to buy
everyone out and I don't feel like doing
I got a good life and so I would you
could do that for these window things
and if I was one of these uh drone
window companies I would look at what
you would do yeah yeah you you wouldn't
necessarily go there
Vesey and try to build this organically
this is more of you take it you know you
take some capital and you start rolling
up these businesses and you already have
technology for efficiency yeah and I
know people who did this I put my
friends from Nationals was just scam
artists and they would do this for the
locksmith industry they would do what
and so so when you roll up the reason
you roll up a company is because you
want to get efficient operations
specific basically if you own 20
different businesses you want to be
dishing off of leads to them so they
constantly have new business coming in
right then and we're actually in trends
we're running a report on hotels Brad is
that gonna go live next week the hotel
thing okay so we're gonna have a thing
this is what Hilton does so they
franchise out the hotels right everyone
knows the Hilton brand centralize the
marketing yes you said everyone knows
Hilton they buy all the ads everywhere
you go to hold kamaboko hotel then they
dish it off to their franchisees so
that's what what was I talking about to
our locksmiths that's what locksmiths do
in Nashville what was scary about it or
you just think these guys generally dami
about it is because they could rank
really easily for Nashville locksmiths
and they don't give you the price and
then when they get there they just see
how much money they can get out of here
gotcha
and then the locksmith who's like
typically where I live there all
Israelis and so they all would knew each
other from Israel and they would come
over and they would be like they would
go to your house and you're in a pinch
yeah really and it seems like the top
ten
Yury reviews you like the reviews and
this one only okay the movies this ones
are kind of good it's all the same
company and they're all the same my
friend owned it right and they would all
it was all the same and then they
wouldn't really tell you how much the
price is and then you'd get there and
they'd be like all right I've been
checking at 200 bucks
and so they've charged the lady there
the customer $200 and then they would
give the owner just like 20 or 30
dollars right so the owner was just a
lead gen machine that's so funny when my
sister had a baby and we the baby was at
a party and would put the baby to sleep
in this room it was like in this like
the bassinet or whatever and we closed
the door so there wouldn't be too much
noise door gets locked
baby's inside baby wakes up starts
crying we realize the doors locked
pretty panicking moment
the window recalled one so-called
locksmith right away Israeli I don't
know if there's really so it's an
Israeli thing
this is in Francisco so maybe not maybe
not as much but maybe it was person
shows up it's like this is like we're
indoors we're not this is not like your
front door like complicated lock it's
like a bedroom doorknob and they're like
four hundred dollars and we were like no
[__] way and then they're like a
chance well if they were like well it's
$400
I can hear a baby crying inside don't
you want to get and we were like you
know just out of principle like no and
then we just busted down the door with
our shoulder and like got in good
because that was just works outrageous
no it was uh it was a good friend of
mine did this he and he was from Israel
and he told me he was Yale for some
reason like it's a trade back in Israel
and so we'll come here then we get all
of our friends to come here and we
dominate the market right like Indians
in motels there's it's not even Indians
there's a specific group of Indians
Indian and Indians love million zone 70
or 80% of all motels
and Dunkin donut area and actually
families with the last name Patel also
because they're like they're sharing
there's a book about this I know what
you Dennis so 98 percent of dentists I
heard about this dental corporation in
Canada that's it that's the so dental
Corp has 168 dentists what was the
revenue are they public there definitely
was a three billion dollar roll up that
I remember looking and then also I
believe Blackrock Blackstone one of
those two they or their heavy in this
business now so as well maybe tomorrow
or Friday let's have a roll up edition
because I can list a whole bunch of
companies that have done this and I'm
crazy so you're saying rather than half
talking about it in half knowing it we
should okay gotcha okay let's move on
and tomorrow we'll know everything about
this industry you want to talk about uh
can you scroll Henry okay so I we can
talk about Boy Scouts and Girl Scouts if
you want I'm interested in a little bit
okay actually here's what I wanted to
ask you about this is different than Boy
Scout so we should talk about Boy Scouts
is this zilean biers thing what happened
yeah what is this okay so barstool just
put a clinic on marketing on how to do
marketing right okay so will tell me the
story I don't know I don't get what
happened barstool sports will will dumb
it down barstool sports media company
like ESPN or bleacher report but
personality-driven and yes being after
three beers base yeah it's just like
comedy it's more it's like SNL it's more
comedy and fiction than it is whatever
journalism yeah yeah sometimes it is
some mean everyone so although I have
some amazing but yeah no it's it's just
a bunch of like it's for the average man
by the average man's but their tagline
okay they have a guy he's a camera guy
and Henry's a big fan so he knows to
they have a guy a camera guy named Dana
Dana was getting made fun of one day
like 10 days ago for drinking too many
beers and he set a line like he tweeted
out and he said some line like I'm just
a guy who drinks a zillion beers and he
starts like talking about zillion beers
over the course of a day and his boss
Dave Portnoy was like dude you're a
cameraman you're not a Content guy quit
the zillion beers stuff yeah stop trying
to make it a thing not try to make it
thing and Dana goes Dave I bet you I can
sell like thirty thousand dollars where
the zillion dollar beer merch and Dave
goes if you do that I'll give you 10
grand or something like that
they blew past it then after a few days
of this going back and forth it gets to
the point of if you sell a million
dollars worth of merch in the next five
days I'll give you a hundred grand right
he has across that he got 1.5 million
and how long do you think that lesson so
he created a brand essentially on the
fly
Zoey Peters brand called zillion beers
and in ten days sold one point six
million dollars in merch and throughout
this process
much the way in which they sold birch
was pretty much all Twitter and so I was
watching like as a marketing person I
was looking Dana went from having a
thousand followers on Twitter to
whatever he has now maybe 150,000
followers on Twitter in 10 days and he
would get into DRA like dry like a
fights like so for example he met this
girl on Twitter and she flew out and
they started like talking about how
they're dating now even though they just
met and then the ex-boyfriend starts
tweeting at him and he's like alright
Mead you we're gonna get in a fight at
rough and rowdy I put a hard grade
online it's on that book that became a
storyline there's like a dozen different
story it's all just happening like a
weekend basically yeah and everyone was
following it in real time I didn't go
out on Valentine's Day because I was
just refreshing Twitter and just like
reading about all of this it was amazing
yeah that is amazing I saw it happening
I didn't understand the full backstory
yeah I I saw what happening I I don't
even drink beer and I bought $150 worth
of zillion beer Berg yeah just out of
respect for what was going on it was
great to support the cause it's like a
it's like a rowdy Kickstarter that he
did I love it yeah and so I think the
takeaway here is like they bar still put
on a clinic of like how fast you can do
stuff yeah and people want to be a part
of something and so it's one thing to
just sell merch it's another thing to be
a part of something which is like oh my
god once it gets the momentum of we're
going for a million holy [__] we're
gonna do it
my boss bet against me helped me beat
the man I think it like it just caught
this wave of it wasn't about the merch
obviously like none of it was about the
merge it was about putting it into
Dave's face right oh you doubted him
we're all gonna get behind him and this
guy Dana the guy behind it he's like a
total bro but he seems like a really
good person and it was fun watching him
like be excited watching him win yeah
and people he put his venmo out there
and I've a mode him like 50 bucks people
ven mode of money collectively he got
like three grand and he went and blew it
all out a fancy restaurant it was funny
seeing like a redneck he at a steak
minute have you seen this guy mr. beast
do you know that is love mr. beast so if
you don't know who mr. beast is he's
this youtuber who's grown like crazy in
the last like 18 months really no he's
he's like a new guy but he's blown past
how many subscribers but maybe tens of
millions subscribers now and his whole
thing is he's just like it just gives
away money to people well like it does
challenges but like he's typically he'll
give away cars so for example he goes to
a used car dealership and he buys ten
cars which each car is probably five or
ten thousand dollars right maybe he's in
40 or 50 grand on this thing and people
come to buy the car and the and he acts
like the salesman and the lady will be
like all right this car looks good and
he goes okay here and you give her the
keys he goes no it's yours right
and they film it and this the reaction
it's kind of like that like it has a
feel-good element to it cuz you see
people who are like no way like what
it's guilty he'll go to a restaurant and
leave a two thousand dollar tip on a $10
bill and they're like people break down
crying and then sometimes it's funny
where he'll be like he'll take four
frames he'll buy a Lambo and be like put
your hand on this Lambo first person
last person to have their handle this
Lambo keeps the Lambo and they just for
two days straight they just have their
hand on this thing they're passing out
and they you know he met he turns onto
YouTube content and he's brilliant
because he gets brands to pay for the
whole thing so this one brand quit are
quid or quick it's not the toothbrush
it's like this like stickers trading
cards thing online at least quid quid
has given this guy you know they'll just
put up the 50k he does the challenge he
spouts out quid and they're happy for it
because their videos are getting like
millions of views and so it's way better
branded content than usual and so he
basically took brand money and parlayed
it into being like huge which is pretty
crazy yeah and he even do a thing where
he raised a hundred million twenty
million dollars for trees trim plant a
tree and the founder of Shopify game 100
or sorry a million Elon gave a million
yeah and he raised 20 million dollars in
two weeks yeah and I have a friend who
talked to him on the phone the other day
to do a campaign and he was like what
friend Jason said Jason Hitchcock
shoutout to Jason so he was like you
know talking to him and he when he kind
of phone he's like yeah I talked to mr.
B he's really cool like talk to his
agent or whatever and he described he's
like you know one weird thing happens
which is didn't plan for this
you know sort of success you get the
success but the YouTube game is such
that you kind of need to top yourself
every time you probably getting exhaust
and so he's like dude the stress
of like okay we gave away a Lambo
through this like crazy thing next week
what do I do like okay it's just this
constant bar raising which is really
tough so when we first launched our
company I get a phone call from
Elizabeth Murdoch you know who is Rupert
Murdoch's daughter yeah okay it's just a
big shot and she was like hey you guys
want to do these videos I'm launching
this new thing and I need video content
and I was like no that's not what we're
trying to do but let's say friends and
shoot the [__] and she goes okay well
I'll find someone else so she finds
someone else to do it and they started a
YouTube channel and that YouTube channel
is now called yes theory I heard it yes
they heard of it yeah they got five or
six million subscribers and I've become
friends with them over the years and
they have a I mean they're like famous
so like legit famous I don't I have no
idea if it's a good business but I bet
you they make they could each pay
themselves a million dollars a year so
pretty good for young people pretty good
for anyone and each week they're having
to do crazy and crazy [__] and they've
had to do this for three years now every
video is like I went to the most remote
island in the world
rabbi cellar head it's three guys now
and they're like taking turns over doing
crazy [__] like it's the crazy stuff was
like I asked my uber driver if she wants
to go to Paris and we went straight to
Paris and went there and now they're
like doing variations of that it's like
oh my god it's like jackass if Stevo and
the Jackass crew had YouTube and like
they would have to do this every week
like we were just lucky that they were
lucky that the cadence was like you know
seasons of TV or a movie because when
it's weekly it's just insane which is
why Casey nice tat and Logan Paul Jake
Paul all these guys eventually pieces
you know they do this daily grind for so
long but they burn out like the content
burn out is crazy for sure it's not
gonna happen to us though well it's not
gonna happen to us we just sit and do
nothing and I don't like having to get
on a plane and like or like Logan Paul
you gotta like yell at someone or like
go break up with a girlfriend every week
I'm gonna go box someone yeah so I got a
Rupert Murdoch story because you said
Murdoch I'm so impressed with this dude
so he gets a lot of hate because like
his business practices and whatnot
people think he's like a tyrant in a way
he is
and like the show success succession is
basically about their family good show
so we had this opportunity to pitch
Rupert Murdoch so Michael who's my
investor comes to me he says hey we got
invited to this thing basically every
year during CES Rupert Murdoch brings
all the CEOs of his companies through
News Corp so they own Wall Street
Journal I think or you're a New York
Post at Vox and Skye and then they own
penguin publishing right I own
realtor.com so he is the media mogul
right like that's cool so basically once
a year they all get together it's during
CES they go to the Wynn and they rent
out the entire top floor of Wynn and so
all the rooms there are all the execs
and they have the biggest suite the
penthouse suite of the Wynn and what
they do is they and I really admire this
they go from 8 a.m. to about 7 p.m.
every single day for two days straight
and every hour is just they just bring
in a speaker not like a speaker it's
like a an industry leader from something
and they just they just grill them so
it's like you you start by just telling
me a little bit about your business and
there's 30 minutes of Q&A from the CEOs
of all these companies because they're
trying to figure out okay how do we play
into this so when I was there it was
like literally CEO of Google CEO of
slack number three guy at Facebook just
back-to-back-to-back the CEO of Google
was the one getting grilled yeah he
would go and he was explained here's
what here's where we're going next year
because these are big media partners for
them they they want to have these media
partners working with them so they'll
say here's what we're going next year
and but it's off the record right so
it's more candid than you're ever gonna
get these guys and I they told me you
can just come for your slot you know
this 45 minutes lot but rupert's there
though but I was like I'm sitting here
the whole day like this is why I didn't
sit there because we were gonna present
at the end of the day and so we had
access I just sat there at 8:00 a.m. I'm
there with my seat so here's what I
noticed during the day a lot of the CEOs
you know they'd be interested in certain
people but for the most part you know
they get hungry they go to the bathroom
Rupert Murdoch I don't how old he is
guys like 80s like he looks old and he
is old and that guy sat right up front
with a paper and a pencil did not get up
did not take a
he was the mostess didn't take a piss he
was the most attentive he asked the best
questions he was like a machine and I
was like that's why this guy's Rupert
Murdoch I was so impressed by this guy
he's just endurance really and also just
his level of focus where everybody else
was wandering throughout the day cuz
that's what you normally do and that's
kind of contagious did he ask what I
loved how the leader was like on point
because it held everybody else like
closer to that standard
did he ask questions yes good questions
yeah what's funny cuz if you're the CEO
of one of his companies already maybe a
billion some of them might be billion M
Europe you're you're up there I don't
know but yeah you may be doing super
well if you felt I could be like your it
was like the CEO of Fox Studios like oh
yeah we make these movies for this year
and it's like oh whatever you know
Marvel like it's like these are big
individual brands you're you're a big
you're a big swing and dick yeah big guy
so that was incredible I just thought
that was really cool and I gotta give
him props for that it was very impressed
that's crazy
okay a different one that's related what
you learn from that thing anything else
trying to think about what else was
important I think another piece that was
that was cool there was setting his
company up for success
cuz the media business I mean a lot of
his stuff was he literally started with
newspapers local newspapers and so very
easily companies like that can miss all
these shifts and become like extinct I
think one of the reasons they haven't is
because it probably has this learning
culture and sounds corny but what he did
was pretty badass was like we're here
we're not gonna go tell these guys what
what what the world is we're gonna be
the listener we're gonna be the student
here and and so I thought that was
pretty badass that he set up he
architected these days which was just
you know action-packed with like top top
people of the world coming and teaching
them about the future and even us like
why did he have us he had four startup
slots you know there's all big companies
they have four startup slots we were one
of the starters thought you guys was
right by him yeah cuz it was like okay
you guys are doing something interesting
was when we were doing blab it was like
okay tell us about the future you're not
big yet but you're growing and we think
you're interesting and so tell us what
you know that the big companies don't
know
and they would ask questions like very
good questions like like that like what
is the if we're us one of the questions
he asked was what is what are we stupid
for not doing like when you look at our
business what do you look at you just
say you are stupid for not doing this
this is our Enterprise version of trends
Brad is having that nice Cyrus that's
what I learned from these guys I thought
was pretty awesome guy that's badass who
are the other three companies one was
Alfred the skim was there
oh are you told me I told you about this
because I was sitting there
Fox is an investor of the skin yeah yeah
I was yes cool in fact I heard the guys
in the back because I was sitting at the
back when that was happening is like
probably not the people who were doing
it or they weren't investors at the time
and they were just like like they were
like yeah this is cool and all but and
they were just like ragging on it in the
back cuz they were just like look you
know here's what the numbers are here's
where it's not big enough yet for it to
matter to us and but Rupert at the front
was kind of like what do we not know
like about this business he wasn't it's
easy if we were a huge conglomerate to
just look at everything and say you're
small you mean nothing and that's what
the guys in the back were doing but at
the front Rupert was sort of like email
interesting tell me more and like was
going through these like you know you
could tell he was searching for what he
doesn't know rather than the guys at the
back thinking they know everything and
not really being open to learning
something new from the people who are
talking crazy Henry can you go tell him
to quit making the dog park I could tell
it's someone saying can you scroll this
down yeah it's cool scroll that down and
then tell them to my [__] dog's
bargain I know that it's like et like
saying you know you want some food speak
so he shot you could edit this go down
to the list of ideas okay a little bit
further or can you just shrink it a
little bit there should be way more
before you had others like a huge gap
before you had the the auctions that's
right
that's fine okay deshaun we're back when
did that part out so one other idea
that's similar to something we were
talking about earlier is this revenge
against the spam calls have you heard
about this yeah I tried to write about
this last year because I bought one of
these apps
robocall yeah Babel caller amazing I did
research on it huge business and that
one of the reasons I know it's huge is
because I did research on them and I try
to find everything and immediately I
knew it was gonna be big because it was
so hard to find information on them so
tell me what that business what what
explain what they do first and I'll tell
you about what this new guys doing that
is interesting this one I think it was
based in New Jersey they have many
different apps one of them being Robo
visor I think it's called and users like
me pay maybe 50 bucks a year and if
someone calls that's clearly a spammer
it goes straight to their voicemail or
if it is a suspicious one it just says
on my voicemail it's suspicious like
right this is a spoof call right and so
I know to avoid and so so that existed
and there's company called true caller
that's huge internationally that does
this true caller caller is like a
universal caller ID we should do an
Android untrue caller it's like it's
like a whatsapp's it's gonna be like a
whatsapp size to exit I think or like
you know that's multiple billions of
dollars on this thing called true color
and it's not that relevant in the u.s.
because we don't have the same problems
if you have internationally with not
knowing phones people switch phone
numbers all the time there dude I get 10
spam calls a day so Apple started doing
this but what this guy is doing is
interesting so so this guy Joshua he has
this company called do not pay I love
this I signed up for it so I do not pay
for those don't know is he follows me on
Twitter so we'll make sure he sees this
yeah so do not pay school so basically
it's like you get a [__] parking
ticket so you know like you can actually
contest a lot of these because either
they filled out the form wrong and
therefore you don't have to pay or
technically you're just wrong you don't
have to pay so it doesn't work as good
as you think though and I'll tell you
why there used to be a company called
fix it yep and I knew people invested in
it I used it in the way it would work is
you would register your license and
anytime your car got a parking ticket
before you even got to your car
the app told you and they automatically
fought fought the ticket in San
Francisco court and you would pay fix it
half the price whatever you got back out
of your yeah and they it would be fun
they would always get it reduced right
it was awesome
San Francisco outlawed it it was just
cramming the system right so these guys
do something instead of a start it off
with that which is you could fight
tickets but it's like what else can we
do what else is like they call
themselves sort of Robin Hood they're
trying to sort of take money and give it
back to the and the guys like twenty
years old very young gets a ton of press
with this very smart that's how he grows
but they have other use cases for
example they have a credit credit card
that you can use that automatically
cancel your free trials so how much
privacy calm offers that it's great
product right and then they have a
couple other ones one is where that were
they they can test what is it they
they've a couple they look for different
things that they can test the new one
that they came out with is we still get
spam calls and so what they do is
twofold there's this thing called the Do
Not Call list or whatever they do not
call registry and so they what if you
download their app what they'll do is
they'll sign your for the Do Not Call
Registry
but the problem is spammers don't care
about the Do Not Call Registry they just
call you anyways because they know that
you're not going to take the time to
like go and you know enforce this you're
not gonna go fight you figure it out so
then they ought to first they put you on
the registry then when you get a spam
call they give you a little credit card
to give to the spammer
and the scammer and when they give when
they use those details they
automatically generate paperwork to sue
them for three grand and so there's like
you can sue for three grand everytime
they commit this mistake and so what
they're doing is they're automating v
like three thousand dollar lawsuit for
for this robo call for this BAM call
thing I just think it's a very smart
model of like saving people money
through these small hacks I like this do
not know this guy has that's a great
segment that we should go through more
of small hacks that make big differences
this guy what's his name
Joshua something I think he's 21 he
raises money from Peter teal a
substantial amount 10 million maybe
maybe yeah okay bullish or yeah bullish
I think these are good I think there's
enough people that are that don't want
to be ripped off in music five ways they
have like five things they can defend
against
and one of those is gonna be like a
repeatable use case that that's gonna
work okay I would say that I am bullish
on the industry bullish on the product
ideas the guy Josh seems like a loose
cannon
yeah which really usually goes the bad
way but the great outliers end up being
right massive and he's getting a ton of
PR because he is what you're talking
about he loves to go and champion the
cause he's great for media the [__]
so he gets a bunch of free PR he's a
huge controversial things yeah okay so
on that note I have a note up here that
says what Charlie Munger said about Elon
Musk so it's directly related to what
you just said so somebody was asking
Charlie Munger hey you know what are
your thoughts on Tesla what are your
thoughts on Elon Musk because it's one
of the most like polarizing companies
he's one of those polarizing CEOs and so
here's what he said I want to know if
you agree with this or not so he goes he
first said you know I wouldn't long or
short the stock I think it's a great
product and he said my most important
comment was this you guys never
underestimate the man who overestimates
himself
I think Elon Musk is peculiar in that he
may overestimate himself but he's not
wrong all the time and when he's right
he seems to be right very big and and so
he said that was the first thing I like
that quote never underestimate the man
who overestimates himself and then the
second thing he said was they said would
you hire Elon as one of your CEOs for a
Berkshire Hathaway company and he goes
no never he goes I want the guy who
understands his limitations instead of
the guy who doesn't you know I've
learned this lesson in life that these
weird guys who over it estimate this up
they occasionally knock it out of the
park but me personally I don't want to
be around a guy around somebody who's in
a lose lives in a state of delusion and
who occasionally happens to win big I
want a prudent person so I want to know
your opinions on this I feel like you're
gonna have a guy like I just said
exactly that yeah so when I try to hire
sometimes certain people I'm like a
loose cannon here could work like I
basically like you hang out with a lot
of these guys like I love the wild card
these like hackers cuz at Sean's old
office it had an apartment and there he
would meet a guy in the Internet
and literally five days later the guy
would fly from Germany and basically
live in that apartment and literally it
would never leave oh yeah I could see
like yeah that German kid yeah ooh I bet
you he could have been in that apartment
for five days and he maybe only brought
a book bag and a teacher right
and then he overstayed his visa
everything is crazy so I like those
types of people yeah I for sure like
them and I like being around them I
don't trust any of them I expect that
they will do mostly nothing but the one
or two times that they pull through it's
gonna be massive massive so I for you
yourself would you say you're more in
the bucket of you know kind of the
delusional type who overestimates and
themself but sometimes knocks it out of
the park or you more the prudent
pragmatic person who takes a realistic
view and is sort of a steady hand and
running a company which type are you
that's a good question or do you have
both gears I think what do you think
Adam is clearly the second type right
Adam is clearly the the pragmatic
diligent steady hand not look not trying
to swing for homeruns full-time I would
say occasionally I'm fine betting at all
if my business goes away entirely
tomorrow because we bet it I wouldn't be
upset so I would say I am closer to that
wildcard one but not entirely right and
then with hiring people it sounds like
you hire mostly for I think naturally
you hire mostly for the prudent steady
hands it's a ratio so I think you need a
few of these loose lose lose loose
cannons right and that's where cool
stuff comes out of but most of the stuff
that they come up with is really dumb
and stupid right and there's also an art
to managing a wild card your firkin it's
a wild card he's a wild card for sure
and he's steady and he you know what I
did with him he's not emotional and I'll
bet it all we hired him and within a few
like weeks I was like hey this guy is
amazing and B this guy's a wild card
like I can't handle him like I can
handle most people in the company and so
I said I literally separated him I was
like look you need to work with people
who are like you because when you work
with these people they're gonna drive
you crazy
because they're so steady they're nine
to five there are no highs no lows
you're just getting what you get and I
was like you will hate that style and so
I said I want you to hire your own team
and only you do the interviews nobody
else is gonna give their input like or
you make the decision you know there's a
CTO you can hire outside what the CTO
wants which was like pretty
controversial at the time so I was like
you hire your own team he hired all
people who had either dropped out never
went to school
these hacker types that were just be up
all night he'll because he knows how to
manage the wild cards and so he hired a
team of while hours basically I love
those people so if you have them in your
team or your company like make sure
you're not just treating them the way
you will because they will be very
frustrated and you won't be getting the
value of their like potential my friend
Jack Jack my best friend Jack Smith he's
one of them solos coming for 800 million
dollars six months ago he got all the
money I was like we couldn't do a thing
he's like I think I'm gonna go and put
all it like in some major bat he was
like yeah I'm about to go buy that like
and he had done that even before he sold
that money he had a fair bit of money
but he not that much in that but he
didn't have any income right on a
consistent basis
he would bet all of it like at least
once a month he would literally have
like a few thousand dollars to his name
yeah and seven figures on some like
short or we gotta get Jack and
consistently he always did that I I know
I don't think that I take risky
investment no I don't think my in are I
don't think I'm that risky I put like 10
or 20 percent of my liquid assets into
very very very high risk things where
it's just probably gonna go to zero I
don't think that's crazy yeah that's not
too crazy especially given the age and
earning potential you have going for
yeah I don't I'll do some crazy stuff
but no I mean I know people that will
literally empty their bank account one
thing right you have any friends like
that um yeah I have I have friends it's
not so much like empty their bank
account on things but I have friends
that once they get to conviction like
sue Lee is like this and we should we
should have him join us one of these
times but he's the type where when he
has conviction in something the
question is not like he did he breaks
all the rules if he's like usual
investing and he'll go and try to like
plow the money in own as much as he can
create a competitor to it you know like
he went when he gets his mind into
something and he believes there's an
opportunity he goes like into hunting
mode like I remember we were investing
in lamb to school and I brought this
deal to the table and I was like hey I
think it's great for these reasons and I
set up the call and like but once he got
to conviction you know the the CEO would
be like hey yeah you're in I'm gonna
send you the docs in a couple days and
silly-- would ask me he's like where
those docks
let's get those docks let's text him
again let's call him and I didn't
realize like I think part of it is like
as an investor it's easy to get squeezed
out you never know what's going on so
you're sort of an old state of paranoia
but the other part was like when he
knows what he wants he goes for it at a
degree that I wasn't used to and then
once I saw it I was like okay that's how
you're supposed to go for these things
well speak kind of Munger he once said
he goes all I do is find in companies
that I can invest in that required no
diversification like the perfect
investment is one where you don't you
don't you don't do any divert
diversifying you put all of it into that
one and I always am looking for those
which you normally will never find one
but you try to find ones close to it
yeah because they go for value investing
so they go for essentially what they
consider a sure bet where it's already
the value is already baked into what it
is I don't do bet on the future I'm
getting it at such a mispriced moment
that like yeah I want to take as much as
I can of that asset because I'm I'm
already sure it's worth that today and
there's just mispriced by the market
good what time is it all right you wanna
do one more yeah so the spam calls thing
was awesome I think we should do a case
study in a couple of these some of them
are big like tens of millions of dollars
business emoted true caller true call
excel on trends you go to transact go
and sign up and we will have a case
study on this in the next week or so and
so you had something's at the top so we
get well we could talk about we could
talk about I think we should talk about
this chest thing real quick cuz I think
it's a good it's a good example business
of a mistake a lot of people make
some behind this exact thing one second
so chess biz 12,000 mr are on 90 kids
okay where'd you get this so in the in
the Facebook group that my first million
Facebook group somebody posted this so
somebody pre off they posted is that hey
I'm a 20 rolled college nearly drop out
here I run my chest tutor calm my chest
atutor calm it's an online chess academy
we currently have about 90 weekly
students it's doing 12 and a half km or
our growth has been slow and as you can
imagine chess is not really like this
you know super wide sort thing its niche
question he's like I really want to
learn about a new high income scale or
take on another high potential project
but I'm not sure where to start you know
I just feel like I'm capped out here and
this was like such a you're not capped
out yeah this was a mistake I would have
made when I was 20 and so immediately I
was like are you joking buying the
business so it's a my chess tutor calm
it's basically a coaching Academy for
chess players young chess players and
just doing 12 and a half thousand Omata
they pay what's that you pay for the
training basically is it like a digital
training or you have a coach I don't
know if it's I think it's coach I think
they match you with a I think you know
there's some revenue split here but I
would say this you're 20 years old you
have this chess thing that only on 90
students which is like 90 is basically
zero you're doing 12 and a half K a
month which is like extremely
respectable for a 20 year old person
who's been doing this thing chess is a
niche yes
but it's way bigger than ninety and in
some of the comments here somebody was
like hey like just so you know like the
US national you know elementary chess
tournament has 2,500 players that's the
tournament that's a 2-1 tournament
that's elementary school just us and so
like you're not capped out by any means
I mean do you think that this guy could
get 5,000 people to pay for this yes
totally I totally agree so what's uh
what's the difference what's that
revenue if he gets 5,000 people I mean
let's just do that here soon and we get
made fun of on the spot math sucks while
you're doing the math Jason Lumpkin
who's an advisor to me won't famous
enough it's not famous but he says it
and he told me he goes if you can get to
10 million in revenue you
can get to 100 million in revenue right
there's these benchmarks if he says I
think if you get to 1 you can get
there's a high chance you get to 10 if
you get to 10 there's a high chance you
get to 100 it may take a long time right
it takes a long time but you want to do
it and his thing is I don't sell early
and this is basically saying don't quit
early so what's it don't get a TD okay
okay make it 140 bucks per kid and if
you had five thousand students enrolled
in this you're doing about seven hundred
grand a month a monthly revenue as you
know an online chess school and I
believe this is achievable 100% now the
question is rarely like a million a year
can this be big enough
typically it's do I raise money or not
in this case rate if you are gonna raise
money make sure it's under a million
dollars
yeah because likely don't raise anything
yeah don't raise anything and if you
could own this business and pay yourself
five million dollars a year yeah and and
also the question is like how do you get
bigger because probably it's what you're
doing the reason you're getting shiny
object syndrome and trying to look for a
new business idea is because you can't
you don't figure out you don't know how
to make more progress in this one and so
you need to get with somebody who's a
little bit smarter than you like I'll
help you just message they do a session
I'm going to the website know is it good
looking as some of you wants to sell it
yeah actually you're capped out [__] it
you should all this to me for 10 grand
worthless okay here's the site you get
business I think you should bail like
what flex debate okay debate yeah this
is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna dominate
the grade school in a high school market
with you so chess debate spelling bee
spelling bee oh my god this is it yeah
this is it yeah we're gonna call it
extracurricular Inc and we're gonna
dominate this it's gonna call it be
called overbearing parent and over but
yeah helicopter tiger mom Inc right and
we are gonna this is awesome
who's this guy what's his name i pre-op
I think in the Facebook group so
shoutouts pre-op get good food for
thought and don't don't quit man do not
quit this is awesome if you need help
right yeah I don't know if you could
hear Brad but he just put some good info
basically sharing how big he wants to it
and once in any money and wants this to
be a cash flow thing I love this I'm
very interested yeah I would invest if
I'm getting like a monthly dividend but
not if I didn't great idea
another great one from the Facebook
group was this restaurant refills thing
I don't if you saw this
so somebody basically said and I should
find their name but they basically were
like hey I own 14 kind of venues I don't
know if it's bars restaurants something
like that and they were like dude you
know I pay Aramark $1,000 per month per
location just to refill my toilet paper
my hand you know like the bathroom like
the toilet paper cut the toilet cover
seats thing like just these like stock
goods how big is it a thousand dollars a
month per location for him how much
revenue does ef I don't know he didn't
share too much about his thing but he
basically said he's refilling it every
one to two weeks from them and so so so
basically that one of the ideas here was
if you were doing restaurant refills
Cisco and air market these giant
companies that do this service and
they're they're very very big and I
wonder if you could go in as a local
player and differentiate on one of these
one of the following levels a just not
shitty service because air mark and
Cisco are so big they're almost
certainly giving shitty service to your
average venue by now the other one is
price and so like can you create a co-op
or a group buying vehicle so that a
bunch of restaurants say hey we're tired
of paying $1,000 a month for this
instead we'll pay $100 a month
membership fees but get all of our goods
at cost instead of with the markup and
so you can have a membership model for
that or you do something where you
actually provide like a better service
you know better quality products in some
way like more higher-end stuff then than
these things but I thought that was a
good kind of like
love these ideas where it just makes you
think I'm not gonna go run and do these
ideas but you start to see the world
differently where you walk into it next
time you go into a restaurant bathroom
and you see the toilet seat cover you're
gonna realize yeah this restaurant paid
for this and somebody's restocking their
toilet maker yeah I always see him it's
called like American made
it's a billion dollar we should look
into them you want to know another one
real quick
Otis elevators right total monopoly on
elevators been around for a hundred
years family-owned probably makes
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
in profit YKK zippers well I told you
about YKK zippers didn't I know I mean I
just I just noticed in high school all
of my zippers say YKK yeah and then the
really good what do you know about them
I don't know anything so I collect
vintage leather jackets if it's a YKK
then you can tell what year it's on a
Talon zipper is even higher n so if it's
a talons if it's really good right and
that same category is a white cone denim
so if it's from cone mill it's a great
denim Factory in Raleigh North Carolina
and so YKK Talon and cone mill denim
it's like the high-end stuff that is the
it's the accessories to all the high-end
stores right and so they're just
factories that have been around for 150
years and will probably exist for
another fifty or hundred years you said
you collect leather jackets I collect
leather jet vintage leather jackets and
denim how many do you have probably ten
thousand dollars worth of leather
jackets and probably five grand worth of
vintage denim that I don't wear and I
just I wear them sometimes okay so we'll
do this as the last one the top thing we
had on our list was this uh my heritage
auction it's like auction place which I
assume is for collectors and this is so
foreign to me because Indian people
don't collect like I'm not gonna collect
an American I think like if I go to my
aunt's house there's no art on the wall
yeah tell me about collecting and how
does companies doing 850 million in
auctions this year I will tell you okay
so in 2008 there was this guy who had a
TV show called American Pickers have you
seen American Pickers okay at the time
have you heard of it I've heard of it
but I thought at the time it was the
second most popular show on cable it was
number two behind Pawn Stars which is
similar and the guy's name on the show
was named Mike wall
and I was a huge fan of mics and when I
lived in Nashville I saw Mike walking
down the street and I walked up to him I
go Mike what's up man let me get a
picture if you look on my facebook you
see the picture I start shooting the
[__] with them and I'm like Mike let me
work with you somehow and so turns out
Mike is opening up a store Nashville and
he lets me help set him up and work
there and so what American Pickers does
is they go to old barns typically in the
South but barns people's hoarders homes
not hoarders I mean it's not junk we
call it junk it's not really junk it's
like old motorcycles old cars neat stuff
that's me old yeah and we'll buy it for
$100 insult for five hundred dollars
will buy an old car for five thousand
dollars sell for twenty and I ran the
store where we would keep a lot of the
cool stuff I mean at this point he made
so much off the TV show he just wanted
to collect the [__] because people love
collecting it I would get people that
would fly in from Australia just to
touch an old gas pump the collectors
were fanatical I would sell old gas
pumps that don't work and are only for
decorations and people be like is that
gas pump the Model A or is that one the
models see like they knew their art
school maybe they would pay three grand
because it's [__] awesome I would buy
that stuff I have signs that cost a
thousand dollars a Mobil gas sign only
just to look at it's cool because it's
part of history and here's the even best
part if you clean it or repaint it or
try to make it nicer it loses all its
value right it has to have patina on it
the stuff with the good patina is best
so if you have an old car and there's
routine I mean patina it's like when you
have a pair of jeans so like basically
Levi's changed how they made jeans in
the 1950s so any pair of Levi's jeans
prior to before 1950 they used raw denim
and the more you Wharram it would get
these cool lines in them and that and
the lines are called patina I so wear
and tear and so a pair of Levi's pre
like before they made that change to
their modern process cost fifteen
hundred dollars and if it has cool
patina and it'll be two grand I see and
so if it has any of this patina in it
it's really valuable and so me myself if
I find a shot jacket which is a brand a
shot jacket my favorite air is the 1950s
with the red liner
or a buco jacket I'll drop 1,000 a 2,000
on it all day and so where did you buy
these things online ever or no impress
you you you can't buy them on eBay so
what I used to do is I used to find
jackets in America that were from the
1950s and I would put them on the eBay
in the Koreans and Japanese would buy
them because this a 44 from the 1950s in
America is no longer a modern 44 it only
fits littler guys particularly the
Japanese and Koreans and they [__]
love that American that American [__]
they love it right and so I would I used
to sell all my stuff on eBay
but eBay wasn't the best marketplace for
it so now there's a lot of niche market
places and you're talking about which
one you scroll up which marketplace top
heritage auctions rayj.com here to talk
ins auctions I've never heard of that up
higher all the way up so they did 850
million dollars they said their biggest
category is coins is it coins and I was
like oh my god people spending tens of
millions of dollars on like thousands of
dollars worth of course by some points I
own hundreds of dollars of coins to go
down more and own coins yeah don't you
think that I'm stupid do you think this
is cool
scroll up there it is it's awesome I
love it
so movie posters yeah so I own some
movie posters so I live in San Francisco
so I don't have too much room but if I
lived in Austin Texas where offices I
would have a warehouse and it would be
full of stuff right now blows my might
now I'm in the market for a 1995
Corvette which is and it's it's like
compared to modern cars it's not that
good but it's it's like a cool year
right I'll probably pay twenty fifteen
to twenty grand for it
I get the cars thing I even kind of gets
the the clothing jackets boo these are
Red Wing boots i buy them for a very
particular type of reason I own a pair
of boots that are like the same brain
but from the 1950s and it costs $800 I
don't wear them they just sit there and
I look at them and you feel good it's
like a museum and the coins one that
those are the ones where I'm just like
what this is only get popular here's why
I'm so bullish on this okay so you have
some money now what was popular when you
were let's just let's just imagine that
you're 50 now yeah because nostalgia
will be more important I think but what
will you what would you let's see what
categories of things
what if I showed you a cassette tape a
VHS tape unopened of home alone one of
my favorite movies great okay how much
would you pay for that right now
zero dollars a lot I like to have now
okay as art okay yeah I guess I would I
guess I would do that I guess I see you
there how much would you pay for that VH
it's unopened completely unopened I mean
I probably wouldn't buy a blessing I'm
imagining I'm in that mother and $40 I'm
yeah i pay 30 40 bucks to just have it
there it's a talking point in the room
okay now let's fast-forward 30 years
would you pay $300 if you could find an
unopened VHS tape and you have kids and
I hope I don't this is a note to me when
I'm 50 don't do it bro put you under
jail by the point it's cool right it's
cool okay I get it
let's do another one what's a car you
don't like cars
is there anything okay here's another
example that came up the guy who started
oculus Palmer Luckey he's bidding online
he tweeted this out he's like who is
bidding against me so he was bidding 260
grand to buy this rare thing which was a
it was a Nintendo made a playstation or
something like that
it's the made by nice anybody is a
PlayStation I don't even what this is I
don't want to look into it I don't want
to research it's awesome he's like who
the hell is bidding this up I'm at 260
grand surely there's no other nerd that
wants this pissed I bought a pair of
snapchat snapchat spectacles I've never
even used them they're sitting it in my
drawer right over here Oh future
remember I was sitting there yeah I'm
just holding I'm holding on to them my
own little area about the Elon Musk
flamethrower okay that's cool just never
hope just don't even open it a lot of
people just don't even over just sit
there and it's just cool to have and
then maybe in 30 years would you pay two
or three or four or five thousand
dollars for that maybe yes maybe this is
why I'm saying it's awesome I think
nostalgia is big money so maybe there's
a company so just to turn this into an
idea hey I think this is interesting and
there's a whole brainstorm around how do
you tap into either nostalgia or
collectors and the fanaticism that they
exhibit but a quick idea here is you've
seen these these apps got like goat and
and stock X like these like streetwear
market places so goat is like a mobile
only way to buy you know sneakers it's
like I'm gonna buy these Yeezys for two
grand I'm gonna buy these rare drawer
for $1,800 and so I tweeted this out or
retweeted this list of top hundred
marketplaces by gmv so by gross
merchandise volume and then goat was
like whatever in the top twenty and you
know that's how kids are basically
spending that much on these like cool
sneakers and the sneaker heads are
spending so much and so I wonder if you
could do a mobile like what they did was
just make a slick mobile only
marketplace for these rare items I
wonder if you could do that and pick
your favorite movie posters coins
whatever clearly there's a lot of demand
and it's just about making sort of a
modern-day marketplace because if you go
to this h8 com it literally looks like
what I imagine a coin collector looks
like then I'll imagine a website it
looks like that
it looks like a 75 year old you know
website that never leaves it's bad I
think this shit's gonna be way more
popular with young people I think that
what I would do is okay like what if I
have a like I'm not poor now what what
did that what was I into when I was like
five six seven eight years old like I'll
see whatever goosebumps and yeah slime
from Nickelodeon
if I saw the entire collection of
goosebumps unopened I would love to buy
that and just have it sit here yeah
that's actually pretty cool okay I would
buy that you see what I'm saying this
how it works right or like imagine you
grew up with like I feel like you're
explaining collecting to me which anyone
listens gonna be like duh what the [__]
but I really do feel that way I'm like
what is motivating people to spend
hundreds of thousands dollars I saw one
of the posters movie are some one of the
comics that was that just sold for 70
grand it's a one page of a comic and I'm
like who is this person with too much
money that is spending 70 grand on this
one page a lot of people it's a lot of
people and it's not 70 grand you have to
think if someone's rich enough to spend
70 GS on this thing it's just like you
spending $10 on earth right are you
buying $100 $100 home alone thing it's
like it's kind of a lot of money but
like who cares it's fun right I also
wonder if there's a market for for first
dibs so like let's say you're coming out
with something an album or whatever
movie why aren't these companies selling
the first like who wants the first copy
ever made of this who wants the first
hook great and just auctioned the first
tibs and create a company that it up
yeah just on the spot dude that's what I
do I'm the [__] Magic Man and so you
you you create this first dibs thing
because then you create new inventory
that doesn't even exist yet you sell it
today it comes out in miniature and I
love it like crazy for this first dibs
okay that's good we can leave on that oh
no real quick so Sean and I are doing
this all the time
but I always have to plug this if you
like doing this on your own time you got
to go to trends Co doc wait trends that
Co and buy a trend subscription and I
think what we did was trends deco slash
million and you'll see a big discount
and I'll tell you one thing the sleep
report you guys did I don't that was
pretty interesting because you see these
things that get hype but then you see
the actual data it's like meditation
gets all this hype watch how sleep is
growing about how the sleep interest is
growing and all the different products
that go around that from beds to pillows
to anti snoring to sleep aids to
whatever so I like that article a lot
and the group I've said this a million
times like all the values in the group
the group is amazing and I I really
enjoyed so sign up but we'll keep doing
this anyway